hey how's it going Wolfgang
so today Marvel released a actual clip
from ant-man and the wasp this isn't a
TV spot trailer it's actual footage from
the movie it's pretty cool it's about 50
seconds long so let's take a look
change of plans
[Music]
[Music]
I want that lab boys whatever it takes
Oh
that on the parish it's filthy
[Music]
there's really not too much to break
down in this trailer because it's really
just a lot of action footage and I think
it's done really well it makes me really
excited to see the move because this
seems like a really great scene but
there are a few scenes that we can break
down so let's start from the beginning
the first thing starts off with the wasp
and Luis trying to get away from Sonny
Burch and all of his henchmen it's a
great chase scene where we hear Sonny
Bert's say I want that lab boys whatever
it takes
into the walkie talkie obviously talking
to all of his employees so the lab that
he is referring to is Hank Pym slap and
if you notice in Louisa's hands is a
tiny building now we have learned from
other trailers because we have seen this
actual footage of Hank Penn's laboratory
beans shrunken down so we do in fact
know that this is Hank films laboratory
and that's why everybody's chasing him
and the next few scenes we see hope pull
off some pretty cool stunts while she
takes out some of the bad guys and I
might add that it seems like she's just
chilling it seems like she's doing this
all with very much ease and the trailers
that we have already seen for this movie
it really seems like hope slash the wasp
is kind of ahead of ant-man as far as
combat goes she's very precise she's
very calculated and I think that's just
something else we're seeing here again
but the main thing to take away from
these scenes is the advancement that dr.
Hank Pym has made with his technology
he's got his tech down so well that he
has infused it with this van and all
that it takes to shrink weren't large
again is just a pool of a lever so I
think we're gonna see some really cool
things in ant-man of the wasp with Hank
Pym technology again like I've said
before many people from Marvel have
already come out and said that ant-man
and the wasp was going to play a major
role setting up and leading into
Avengers 4 and I think it all comes down
to Hank Pym I think this is all about
the quantum realm and how they can use
the quantum realm to travel through time
the film is going to take place many
years after the first ant-man movie so
that gives dr. Hank Pym plenty of time
to perfect his tech I mean again he's
already figured out how to infuse his
tech
in a van to where it can shrink and
enlarge just by pulling a lever so we
know that this move is going to be super
important we know that it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be action-packed I think
overall it's just gonna be a great great
movie
it comes out in almost two weeks and
we're all really excited to see what
we're gonna find out that leads us into
Avengers 4 so that's it for this video
let me know what you all thought of this
new clip from ant-man of the wasp and
let me know what you're most excited for
when you see it hit that like button
before you leave please and subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
ant-man I'm the lost Avengers for all
things Marvel and DC thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]